من جهته قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه عقب الاجتماع انه لا يمكن الحديث
عن اتصالات بين الجانبين في الوقت الذي
تستمر فيه واشنطن في قمع الصين واحتوائها
على حد وصفه وشدد على وجوب التعامل بشكل
صحيح مع قضيه تايوان
يجب على الولايات المتحده تصحيح فهمها
للصين والعوده الى العقلانيه والحفاظ على
اس العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه وتحقيق
النجاح المتبادل في تنميه افضل للبلدين لا
يمكن التحدث عن الاتصالات من ناحيه
والاستمرار في قمع واحتواء الصين من ناحيه
اخرى لا يمكن قول شيء وفعل شيء اخر يجب
التعامل بشكل صحيح مع قضيه تايوان والتوقف
عن الاستمرار في افراغ مبدا الصين الواحده
من مضمونه ووقف دعم قوى استقلال تايوان
الانفصاليه
ناصر عبد الحق اهلا بك ناصر عن سياق هذا
اللقاء وما خلص اليه
نعم مريم سياق هذا اللقاء ياتي بعد ما
تقول الصين بانه تحركات امريكيه
اثارت لديها الكثير من الغضب حيث لاحظت
الصين ان الولايات المتحده تتصرف بغير ما
تقول فبينما تعلن الولايات المتحده في
اكثر من موقف
بدعمها واعترافها بمبدا صين واحده الا ان
الولايات المتحده تمارس على العرض اشياء
تخالف هذا الاعتراف
فترى الصين ان دعم الولايات المتحده
لمن تسميهم الصين
بالانفصاليين في جزيره تايوان وتقصد بذلك
الحكومه في جزيره تايوان وذلك من خلال
دعمها بصفقات السلاح التي كان اخرها
اتفاقا بين الحكومه الامريكيه وحكومه
تايوان
بصواريخ خاصه بطائرات اف عفوا اف 16 هذه
الصفقه كبيره للغايه وتقدر باكثر من 6
مليارات دولار وذلك ما تعارضه الصين جمله
وتفصيلا بالاضافه الى كما نذكر خلال الشهر
الماضي قامت رئيسه الحكومه في تايوان
بلقاء
رئيس البرلمان الامريكي مكارثي في
كاليفورنيا وذلك ايضا ما اثار امتعاد
الصينيين والصين تطالب الولايات المتحده
كونها تعترف اذا كانت تعترف بمبدا سين
واحده فعليها
التوقف عن التواصل مع من تسميهم
بالانفصاليين في تايوان اضف الى ذلك مريم
انه في الخامس من الشهر الجاري اي قبل
ايام كان هناك وفد صنا امريكي في تايوان
وكان يراس هذا الوفد رئيس
عفوا رئيس
المارينز الامريكي في منطقه المحيط الهادئ
الرئيس السابق الامريكي في منطقه المحيط
الهادي والذي اعرب في خطاب من تايوان بان
بانه يجب دعم تايوان بالاسلحه المتقدمه
لتكون قادره ذاتيا على الدفاع عن نفسها
وذلك ايضا ما اثار امتعاد الصين مره اخرى
اللقاء الذي جرى بين وزير الخارجيه الصيني
والسفير الامريكي
ياتي في يعني يشير الى مدى اهميه ما تريد
ان الصين ان توصله من رسائل الى الولايات
المتحده حيث
ذهبت من خلال
والعلاقات الدبلوماسيه ان النائب لرئيس او
نائب لوزير الخارجيه الصيني او احد رؤساء
اقسام وزاره الخارجيه هو من يجري اللقاءات
مع السفير الامريكي لكن ارتات الصين ان
يلتقي وزير الخارجيه بالسفير الامريكي هذه
المره لتوجه رساله الى الولايات المتحده
عن مدى اهميه ما تطرحه الصين ومدى قلق
الصين في هذا المجال نعم عبد الحق مديره
مكتبنا من بيتجين شكرا جزيلا لك